excuse me why me why not which one
outside the mosque do you know something
I don't I don't buy the Muslims I'll
fight I'll fight extremists that's
that's actually what for the Clinton one
to whilst you right yeah well I mean
I've had a few fights you know over the
years you know not Weaver not we rally I
mean obviously you know I mean or not
we've missed a hijab you guys do either
be no you got me come feel what I want
to say if someone's wrong one yes then
they're no wrong it doesn't really come
into religion an appointment you've said
a few things in a pasta now I'm going to
bring a beast it's what you've said is
it is that you believe a child whatever
classes a child okay
isn't is would be at the if they decide
that they mature enough to have sex then
that's a decision that they should make
now my argument is today early you have
when your winnings of win when he's a
woman when they win it when he when he's
a woman would a child it's a woman or
child ready for a sexual relationship
when bonus Google or Alexa I'm asking
you Alec yeah a woman who reaches the
age of yeah yeah if she's mentally
sexually and
yep if there is no harm factor okay so
this is what I find that what's great
about Islam and the Sharia law and the
one that you think of everybody getting
chopped up here nothing like that yeah
so the reason why is because they'd be
blessed good man Weston the West no no
sorry sorry our law says one shoe fits
all sam says no because a female who's
16 years old yeah it's not all the same
yeah so she may not be she might militia
age of puberty s 1619 he's actually
physically but I stomp says if she
there's a pumpkin so when there's a
woman's I said when is a girl physically
ready so it's done does it say once she
fits all this now says each individual
girl yeah has her rights yeah I physical
right that's one thing the Sharia came
to protect yeah okay so the thing is
that in this country says you're 16
okay you can have sex even though we
know teenage girls having sex in the
bushes and getting pregnant
so one can see this it is chemically we
don't see to our daughters oh how do you
know I'm in the same bracket any
daughters reach the age of puberty yeah
yeah are you gonna force it upon get a
boyfriend
the question now I want to ask you see
we know what I need of it no no you say
no no no I'm I'm asking I'm asking you a
question
well you're not well I've got your well
maybe in your mind
if he if again okay is between the ages
of nine yes okay and sixteen okay anyway
in okay they could be mature enough in
your in your view if you go to some of
the country's nineteen in Turkey
eighteen yeah so do you see the problem
with giving it a number not over here I
don't know the you know do you have a
problem with a country giving it an age
limit legally okay everybody now
fourteen because there might be a girl
that's forty or fifty or sixty that is
not ready but legally a man might come
and say okay let's go out and we're
gonna have intimacy now maybe she said
she'd be ready they would do
there's some verses in surah nisa it's
gonna circulate the passion and the
arguments that I pad is your password
666 is that what you put in way honestly
Ali just so you know I have a doubt then
2 : the bank the bank details are we
better now to say that we live in
it sounds probably comedy oh that's not
great so that you know what you think
it's okay to marry someone between the
age of 9 okay and and and six things 15
yeah I just wanna know if you think that
I'm asking what you believe that you
can't ran the houses okay memory verse
six and Reed's in three years indicates
that the peace be upon him really yes it
does because if this argument of can be
in a beautiful yeah if this was an
argument the question that least be
asked is why would a pedophile say I
have the power now I'm asking would you
believe Ali
a three-hour drive
aye aye Cannella
[Laughter]
Scotland Yard do not be coming with me
[Applause]
she was 954 are you telling me now I'm
asking what you believe Ellie what you
believe today that I need to I need you
to clarify do you believe it's okay to
have every relationship that's what I'm
asking no no I'm asking what Ellie
believes now no I'm not asking history
imagine what a leave believes you know
you know and yeah I'm not asking you a
better welfare I'm asking if you think
it's okay to have sexual relations
Weaver a girl between the ages of 9 and
15
so with someone having the right a
profit I just wanna know if you well I
just wanna know your personal opinion is
that you don't agree you con you so you
don't agree we like even if you know the
Quran even if I said this the bigger
guys if the Quran says that and you
disagree with a would you say to do you
don't agree with it
okay you're following a prophet
following the Prophet peace be upon him
he married you don't believe that then
you don't today you don't believe
conversation first meeting at night
shows us something here three years he
waited it shows us that she wasn't ready
to consummate the marriage what that is
is the following even annoying even
answer sorry gone know what that
teachers means this yet but if a girl
isn't ready to get married then I can't
marry her because the property weight is
three years
I'm sorry because I saw the video you
made winter when you were talking about
the sister at the little like thing on a
neck remember that video you might yeah
you know you're talking about the sister
the one yeah you want a towel just to
sum up which is the special Rob and I
don't know I thought it was his daughter
I said and he said oh so I don't know
maybe the Marie I don't know I don't
know yeah so it will use a nice
discussion and they're sort of
misconceptions that he has because he
came with I want to see an agenda but
he's got same way of thinking so it
should be understood working on it say I
would like to advise myself and others
as well is when we debate somebody so
for example sometimes we have to debate
with an atheist yeah and sometimes we
have this perception in our heads that
every atheist that we talk to so the
Atheist I talked to last week who is
arrogant who is in listening
I'm gonna treat the this new atheist the
same way as he notices wrong yeah Rob is
a gentleman he came he had some
misconceptions he asked me some
questions and I answered and I believe
the best form of Dawa that we can give
is with good behavior and I hope Rob
left with a calm heart that he doesn't
think that we're here to take over
Sharia law and kill the pigs wherever we
find them it was a nice discussion I
just hope yeah God guides him and myself
insha'Allah and that's a buyer and hope
you guys have benefited subscribe to
some Darwin sha Allah may Allah bless
him for his work assalamualaikum
warahmatullah better here